depuis septembre 2021 la zone
d'activités économiques de bucca
accueilli deux nouvelles stations gnv
bio gnv gnv signifie gaz naturel
véhicule il représente une alternative
au tout pétrole produit à partir de
méthanisation de déchets organiques
agricoles de stations d'épuration ou de
biodéchets le gnv ou biogen v a quelques
avantages ce sont des avantages des
bénéfices environnementaux en particules
fines moins de nox également de
particules de dioxyde de l'oxygène le
carbone - 2
de nuisances sonores on considère qu' à
peu près 50% de moins de bruit associé à
une motorisation ou gnv en partenariat
avec versailles grand parc et grdf les
entreprises nicollin et coved
spécialisée dans la collecte et le
traitement des déchets déploie des
véhicules qui roulent grâce à ce nouveau
carburant le retour il est plutôt
positif comme tout changement on a eu
des interrogations ces interrogations se
sont levés au fur et à mesure de notre
exploitation est mise en place est fait
de manière optimale tous les doutes
qu'on pouvait avoir sur notamment le
délai de remplissage l'autonomie des
camions
l'adaptation aussi à notre territoire
ce type de carburant s'est fait vraiment
de manière optimale la mise en place de
ces nouvelles stations permettra
également à ces deux entreprises de
continuer leur activité malgré
l'instauration de la zone à faible
émission dans la métropole du grand
paris d'ici 2024 la motorisation donc et
le carburant donc
biogen vais en fête et de critères un
don qu'il satisfait la zone à faible
émission de la métropole le grand paris
dont cela permet pour à la fois des
particuliers et des entreprises ou des
collectivités de pouvoir circuler
librement continuer à exercer leur
activité même dans un territoire soumis
aux conditions de la défense nous les
véhicules au gaz sont des critères 1
donc vont pouvoir avoir accès à cette
zone et du coup nous ça va nous
permettre de pouvoir continuer notre
activité en ile-de-france 1400 autobus
fonctionne grâce à ce gaz naturel et une
dizaine de nouvelles stations biogen v
sont prévues d'ici à la fin de l'année
[Musique]